nous avons demandé à un collaborateur de
consulter cinq dentistes pour voir ce
qu'on lui propose comme plante
traitement dentaire comment ça s'est
passé
je l'aï été d'après variété de
propositions qu'une variété pris cinq
dentistes et 5 résultats très différents
un artiste propose de traiter deux d'un
an nombre d'en réparer 15
même la façon de traiter les dames n'est
pas pareil par exemple pour l'instant 17
de martial des prêts savall une sainte
réparation à l'ablation de la danse en
passant par un traitement de canal et
une couronne et des prix qui varient
entre 175 et 2409 pourtant on parle de
la même dans le dentiste avec son juge
d'incliner pense que la façon de régler
des situations qui devant lui avec ce
patient alors c'est la solution à ou la
solution b ça peut être très simple mais
ça peut être aussi très a démarré un tel
écart entre les plans certains sont 20
fois plus cher que les autres a de quoi
rendre les consommateurs perplexe je
trouve que tu as peut-être un petit peu
trop élaboré pour un moment donné à
prendre le temps de pouvoir j'imagine
vérifiez sait comment revenus pour
essayer de me proposer un plaque se
recueillir en fonction de quelques
autres de la banque
le dentiste propose un traitement et
déshonorant de rattacher sur le patient
discute avec il doit en discuter avec
son dentiste s'y trouve ça inquiétant ou
douteux il faut qu'ils en parlent avec
son artiste
nous avons demandé aux trois facultés de
médecine dentaire du québec d'analyser
ces plans de traitement afin de
comprendre pourquoi ils varient autant
d'un dentiste à l'autre toutes ont
refusé on nous a suggéré s'adresser à
l'ordre des dentistes puisque son rôle
est de protéger le public
mais lord aussi à refuser de faire cette
analyse ici que là vraiment radio canada
montréal